como bien comentabas Valentina la
operación por tierra y por aire que ha
lanzado Israel en el campo de refugiados
y según las últimas informaciones que
han dado a conocer las fuerzas israelíes
han desarmado 11 artefactos explosivos y
han desmantelado un pozo subterráneo el
que servía como almacén de armas la
continuidad de esta operación no está
definida Por cuánto tiempo va a ser más
allá de que el asesor de seguridad
nacional israelí salchi y janetti ha
dicho que estaban que están cada vez más
cerca de conseguir sus objetivos
Mientras tanto la situación en el campo
es bastante delicada para los civiles
hay casas destruidas falta de energía
eléctrica y de luz también de alimentos
una situación que varias agencias de la
ONU han descrito como alarmante sobre
todo por la imposibilidad que están
encontrando algunas ambulancias para
alcanzar y atender a los heridos
mientras que según el alcalde de yenín
ya son 4000 las personas que del campo
de refugiados para resguardarse de los
combates Mientras tanto tanto aquí en
Jerusalén como en amplias partes de si
Jordania ocupada se está llevando a cabo
una huelga general en rechazo a esta
este ataque israelí en el campo de
refugiados de chenin y también como una
muestra de solidaridad con los civiles
palestinos en el campo de refugiados
Federico y hace poco Israel informó de
un atropellamiento Y apuñalamiento ante
la VIP que dejó seis heridos al menos
seis heridos el grupo islamista jamás
reclamó que el perpetrador es uno de sus
militantes y se trata de una retaliación
por la operación en yin que más se
conoce hasta el momento
hay que decir que lo que se sabe es que
un hombre embistió con su vehículo
contra una parada de autobuses contra un
grupo de personas que esperaban en una
parada de autobús en el norte de tel
aviv posteriormente bajó con un cuchillo
y alcanzó a atacar al menos a una
persona más antes de que civiles armados
terminara matándolo cabe recordar que en
Israel el servicio militar es
obligatorio para la mayoría de la
población por eso en muchos civiles se
portan armas y esto es algo que celebró
el ministro de seguridad de interior y
Tamara benjivir el extremista de quien
reclamó que todos los civiles israelíes
que tengan permiso para aportar armas eh
lo hagan eh en principio siete fueron
reportados heridos es tres en estado de
gravedad Mientras que el atacante fue
identificado por el servicio de
inteligencia como un joven palestino de
20 años residente de sijordania que no
tenía permiso para entrar a Israel y
tampoco antecedentes por lo que se
investigan sus motivos hay que aclarar
que jamás en no reivindicó al atacante
como un miembro de sus fuerzas pero sí
celebró el ataque y lo calificó como una
respuesta inicial de lo que se llama la
resistencia Palestina frente a la
agresión